this was one of the most amazing videos
i've ever seen and i've been meaning to
ask you this
ever since i saw this video
so this is very important are you gonna
play it from here mark i'll play it and
it's a little graphics
just uh just a bear bear with me because
i was there
so
yep
luckily i was there to do that
now why did you think that was the thing
to do that's what you're supposed to do
hey man someone breaks their arm you
reset it as quickly as you can how many
arms have you reset in your career uh
uppers in the group of one
that's how many girls are conscious
that's actually that's cool
why did he let you do it
he didn't say get the [ __ ] off of me no
he could have said leave me alone don't
touch me bert you have no [ __ ] clue
to talk about you're drinking a gallon
of gatorade today there's no way i think
we need to i think we need to we you're
focusing on the wrong thing okay
the he was the one that put it backwards
like that okay that's the thing that's
wrong
i mean he hurt himself yeah yeah he has
to run he goes to jump right no he fell
on it no no no no no no he he goes to
jump and tom was like 270 this time yeah
and his body wasn't set up to hold 270.
yeah yeah so as he went to leap off
that's a funny way calling him fat this
leg exploded yeah so his patella
ruptured and he went to grab himself and
stop himself with his arm but as he did
that it snapped and spun in a circle now
that that's not good yeah that's that is
the impetus that is the thing we should
focus on yeah not my resetting it it was
going do you think they were gonna leave
it like that for the rest of his life
and then like leave it there leave it
there over there no one's going to touch
it someone's going to eventually reset
it
do you think when they got him onto the
on the [ __ ] gurney that they were
going to go no no leave his arm back
behind him like he's trying to pick his
own pocket but honestly it's not someone
named the machine that doesn't know but
they were just going to flip it around
they're going to flip
so i did that what i did a lot of people
have come out and said that i probably
saved his life
[Laughter]
guys thank you so much for watching that
clip from the flag or two podcast and i
just need to let you know it is march
madness and the national championship is
up for grabs and so is the bag with my
bookie sign up today at my bookie and
use the promo code flagrant to secure a
first deposit bonus up to one thousand
dollars it's simple deposit 200 and play
with 300 instantly just use the promo
code flagrant to claim your bonus mobile
or on the go college or nba no matter
the league no matter the minute my
bookie puts the action in your hands so
you can turn any game day into a payday
bet anything anytime anywhere with my
bookie